what kind of visualization
do you like do you do when you're trying
to think about
we'll get to combinatorial algorithms
but just algorithms in general
yeah what kind of what what's inside
your mind when you're thinking
about designing algorithms
or or even just tackling any any
mathematical problem
well i think that usually an algorithm
is uh involves a
repetition of some inner loop
and and so i can sort of visualize the
um the distance from the desired
solution
as iteratively reducing
until you finally hit the exact solution
and try to take steps that get you
closer to the try to take steps that get
closer and having the certainty of
converging
so it's it's racist it's basically the
mechanics of the algorithm is often very
simple
um but especially when you're trying
something out on the computer so for
example
um uh i did some work on the traveling
salesman problem
and um i could see there was a
particular function that had to be
minimized and it was fascinating to see
the successive approaches to the minimum
to the optimum
you mean so first of all traveling
salesman problems where you have to
visit
uh every city without ever
the only ones yeah that's right find the
shortest path through certain cities
yeah uh which is sort of a canonical
standard a really nice problem that's
really hard
right exactly uh so can you say again
what was nice about the objective being
able to think about the objective
function there and
maximizing it or minimizing it well just
that the um as the algorithm proceeded
it was you were making progress
continual progress
and and eventually getting to the
optimum point
so there's two two parts maybe
maybe you can correct me but first is
like getting an intuition about what the
solution would look like
and or even maybe coming up with a
solution and two is proving that this
thing is
actually going to be pretty good uh what
part is harder for you where's the magic
happen is it in the first
sets of intuitions or is it in the
detail the messy details of actually
showing that it is going to get to the
exact solution
and it's going to run at this
at a certain complexity
well the magic is just the fact that it
the the gap from the optimum
decreases monotonically and you can see
it happening
and um various metrics of
what's going on are improving all along
until finally hit the optimum perhaps
later we'll talk about the assignment
problem and i can
illustrate illustrates a little better
yeah
you